the whole time I was seeing him I was
kind of just using it as a psychology
experiment and I didn't really I didn't
really like the guy I more just wanted
to see if I could break his heart and
it was fun so did you break his heart
then just a wee bit I hope I did a
little damage
that's easy
does she look so sad
no but yo you know I mean you know when
you look at somebody and they'll just
look broken bro yeah you know she's
she's I'm looking for saying her weird
looking smile her whole outfit her whole
look and I'm just like bro I don't know
what happened in Union but you are
busted yeah something really broken on
the inside of you and you know what they
say right the old adage hurt people hurt
people this is a prime example of this
[__] but this [__] is gonna be yeah
it's gonna she's not done getting broken
yeah she's gonna happen she got she got
a lot further down too [__] gonna happen
to her but yeah just try to sit in be
the fly on the wall for her therapy
session find yourself a whole ass movie
script cause this girl is bro but she's
about to get me yeah she's gonna be
about to get she's going to get done up
watch it brother done up wow okay why do
you hope that you did a little damage
just I like humbling men you see that
whole response the reason why she said
she like humbling men is because someone
treated her like Trey
someone out there treated her as
disposable and she got butt her bike and
so now she comes back like I'm gonna
humble you to show you I'm above you
the only guys who like to say I like
humbling women are people who have to
deal with their
whatever right they felt mistreated or
like poorly done
so that's why you come back and you try
to do the same thing
you're looking at a broken person now
doesn't mean you have to sit here and be
like sympathize and like
you don't have to do all that I'm not
saying that I'm just saying understand
where it comes from so you can just know
how to adjust you get me
she said she like humble in me okay you
like humbling man yeah it's like my past
time
your Pastime is humbling men you do work
at a strip club so do you humble men
there
no I take their money
Hey listen I don't know if this is a big
old stereotype but like the whole idea
like strippers being broken
is that a stereotype
because the strippers I know who we left
the game will tell me like most of the
girls in there broken drugged out or
strung out on something if it ain't cash
bro
um
most of them are
yeah you're gonna find you're gonna find
uh a couple of them that are not they're
doing this for whatever reason it's not
not broken that's not the majority to be
a law student pay off their that's not
what I said to pay off their their med
school yeah ain't that the script of a
couple of movies I'm a stupid yeah but
it's the payoff med school that's that's
a bunch that yeah that's a minority that
is a minority okay a lot of them a lot
of them are broken and it's fine that's
fine
let me do yeah it's not all of them of
course there's a couple dollars I'll
tell you there's a few jam and a few
people like that but there's a lot boy
I mean
let's keep it a stick the environment
itself is an environment where there's a
lot of pressures to do certain things to
do extra extra with people that probably
wasn't on the face of the whole
employment contract when you started
there is an action Employment contract
but you get what I'm trying to say and
backstage yeah
you know doing all this stuff and having
to mentally cope with it people got to
do a little extra extra to be able to
mentally accept some things
you don't do that unless you're a little
bit busted on the inside
they don't want to see this people get
back like oh my gosh she's hurt people
and absolutely there's probably like a
trail of Devastation she leaves behind
when she hurts these people that she has
fallen love with her you know mm-hmm
but you remember remember we talked
about the dudes who can't call
yes right
and the reason why a lot of men end up
catcalling right especially oh well [__]
you didn't bit right it's because
they're so used to rejection this is the
only way that they know how to cope I'm
just gonna make it myself I'm gonna yeah
that's the reason why you rejected me
I'm gonna make it a reason yeah I'm
gonna you know I'm gonna yeah rather
than Being Earnest and coming at you
like who I really am I'm gonna be this
like weirdo who's like hey what's up Ma
like you don't normally talk like that
but in front of the ladies you're gonna
act all gross and big or whatever it
might be because you are like that
uncomfortable with yourself and don't
want to be rejected for who you really
are you'll act outside when she says no
I'm like [__] I don't even want you
anyway most of you guys don't even know
that right right right it's a
self-defense mechanism yeah because if
you're comfortable with yourself and
you're good with yourself you're not
doing that no especially if you try to
talk to a girl you're trying to Mac on
her you're gonna just come up with her
offer it like this is what I am that's
what it is yeah
this is another form of self-defense
mechanism where you sabotage any type of
relationship by saying I'm gonna get up
before you can even fill me up because
men have always [__] me up so I'm
gonna [__] you you know what I mean so I
watch this I just think it's sad it's
sad for the people that she's gonna hurt
it's saying for her you know I mean
she's gonna look back on this years from
now and realize how sad is or maybe not
maybe she'll turn some drug addict who
knows what's gonna happen but
um yeah this is just a young person
who's not coping well with whatever's
happened to them and decides to inflict
pain on other people
that's what it is and guess what there's
a lot of us are out there doing it some
knowingly some unknowingly
that's the truth a lot of people are
perpetually going out there in their
dating experiences and hurting other
people oh sociopath
sometimes it's not that oh sorry so
explain no that's not what I said so I'm
not saying I'm not gonna labor her that
but I'm gonna say it the Tendencies are
there
there's a lot of sociopathic uh uh
Tendencies and that [__] that doesn't
mean that she is absolutely that but
it's a disregard whether you
um do this for self-defense or for other
reason the the end result is the same
like you're you you're total disregard
for people's feelings right you you
don't care you don't care whether it is
for you I don't have to care well I
can't care about at the end of the day
it becomes the same
I don't I mean I don't know maybe maybe
not but do you not think there's a
difference between those two things here
let me explain
because the difference between I'm
unable to feel empathy and I've been
hurt so hard it's now difficult for me
there's some people who are broken on
the inside due to past trauma where they
can no longer be affectionate or open or
emotional with people that doesn't mean
that they're sociopathic they no longer
have any emotions I think it just means
due to their experiences they've built
up defense and I agree but I think that
um the end result is the same see what
you're saying changes can changes the
the intention right sometimes it's just
some people is how they're born they're
unable to do that they unable to show
empathy or whatever they don't give a
[__] and there are some people
out of some [__] up [__] that happened
or because out of anger because of what
it is they go into those behaviors at
the end result if people are getting
hurt and you have a disregard for
people's feelings over yours whether
it's because you cannot have those
feelings or because you put in just you
put yourself in a position that I'm not
supposed to have those feelings and you
cut those off the intention is different
absolutely you're right but the end
result is the same what do you mean to
the end result you mean like the person
being hurt or other people the person
being hurt and also the uh uh what you
are engaging in the the the the the
things that you're engaging in are the
same the intentions are not the same the
reason why you're engaging in those
actions are not the same but the end
result is you are engaging in that right
right if I call you like a murderer the
reason why you murdered are gonna be the
intentions are going to be different
right you're still going to be labeled a
murderer if you murder out of
self-defense or you murder out
let me rephrase that the action is going
to be the same right you murdered the
label is yeah the label is there and
then it matters because the labor
doesn't just infer intent but also in
first treatment that's one example I
agree with everything that you just said
in regards to what the actions and the
outcomes are but I think separating the
labels is extremely important not
associating them is also extremely
important because we treat them
differently if someone is sociopathic
then you want to give them a complete
different different treatment method
that if someone just just had some bad
experiences and just needs some therapy
or some good experiences to turn it
around right there's a difference
between somebody who's fundamentally not
born with certain circuits and someone
who's been broken and I'm gonna go back
to what I said what I said was that we
could go back on and say for that I said
there's some sociopathic behaviors right
it doesn't mean that it's certainly the
same and there's some difference between
a sociopath and that and what is is the
same is the actions not the intention
and oftentimes the intentions gonna go
ahead I'll ask you what's your potential
when you're um
you're aligning the two I'm actually
curious like what is the reason why you
are saying like these are similar
they're similar because of the actions
that are taken into in order to do that
the disregard for the disregard for
people's feeling and uh the the lack of
empathy for other people is going to be
the same now the intention is going to
be very different and that's what's
going to differ that's gonna work what's
going to differ into the labeling I
think you misunderstood my question my
question is not like what is like why
are you making that
similarity why are you when we're
looking at this Behavior saying this is
bad this person's mistreating other
people why are you drawing the parallel
to sociopathy because when you whenever
you have a label like that uh this
um a disorder like that you need to you
need to scratch off many uh labels in
order to categorize someone as a
sociopath right and you can have certain
Tendencies without being a social Bible
which have sociopathic tendencies her
she does but I wouldn't necessarily
label her that because I'm not a
professional and I haven't done uh the
the the the the the proper sentence to
label that so I could say that it's the
same direction but it's not necessarily
the same thing that's why I'm saying
that what she's doing is as that but not
necessarily that let's say you have
schizophrenic Tendencies it doesn't mean
that you are that you're gonna do
something that are very similar to but
you cannot be labeled that you're going
to be something else if we do more tests
and everything and stuff you're going to
be labeled something else right so
there's something whenever we talk about
some someone that is um
what's the word it wasn't as
self-absorbed and everything and stuff a
narcissist yeah some people are going to
have narcissists and tendencies right
they're not not being a narcissist is
actually a thing it's a a mental thing
right that you have you have to have
labels and stuff like that and there's
some what I was with you until you
brought up narcissism that I'm like oh I
think I'm against you again I was with
you it's like you complete changed my
mind and then once you brought my I
actually [__] hate it when people say
this person has narcissistic Tendencies
and the only reason I hate it is because
I think it's created a culture in our
society where people start attributing
mental health thing even though it's not
what the original person intended people
now started to say narcissist
I agree I actually agree with you with
what you're saying I just think as a
result of using that kind of language
everybody just throws mental health and
not everywhere now I'm super careful
yeah to ever say it or to actually get
up and I agree with you because people
took that [__] and heard it somewhere
and they throw it like cheese at a
[__] Pizza Factory
they just threw he's a narcissist he's
not but they don't really comprehend
what it is to actually be narcissists
and that's what and that's what I was
trying to say yeah to be to actually be
that it's an actual mental disorder and
you have to check a lot of [__] lists
before you're actually labeled that and
not if all my exes are narcissistic only
three percent of the world is
so you can't always be that and you
cannot be but you can have Tendencies
it's just that people the Tendencies
thing and the reason why you triggered
is people just [__] use that and they
fling it like kale in California
like somebody's selling from like
postpartum oh the [__] is bipolar no
she's just going through like a severe
amount of depression and it's [__] up
her hormones like sometimes you have a
hormone on Bounce you're not actually
bipolar people throw these words around
so casually that they start to mean
nothing and they turn into [__] word
soup and what is bad about it is that
when you deal with somebody who is
actually suffering from these diagnoses
yeah you have a hard time acknowledging
or accepting their reality they're not
severe because most people who are
diagnosed and are actually like treating
it are very measured in their behavior
but they want to find good strategies to
be able to meet and cope with people but
we're not creating a culture where
people are like walking away from mental
health or like [__] on the labels
and I understand why they're [__] on
it because everyone's just throwing that
[__] oh like cheese but again that is
another discussion and not the
discussion we're having now you're
saying that I'm not right you said that
you you love I lost you no because I
hold on because I use that and that's
another discussion because people are
using it what I always wanted to say is
that people are going to have and and
I'm talking about if we're talking about
medical terms I agree in medical terms
but but I do agree that people just I
think we just have to stop using those
words unless it's actually you know why
you know what [__] want to know
that they know what it is oh this is
that it's exactly they want to be able
to pinpoint what things are really I
agree with everything you said I just
disagree with you using it that's all I
actually agree everything you said made
perfect
I don't know I don't even disagree with
you using it I think you used it
correctly yeah I'm not the one that's
wrong it's not me yeah if the [__]
that hurt you huh
it's not me it's not me don't put this
[__] on me hey hey you know what you
nailed that [__]
you nailed that [__]
I've been hurt it's not me it's the
[__] that called you that without a
reason you're crazy
don't talk about that okay because they
hurt me okay and this is always one of
my biggest pet peeves you know you go
through life and you try to be a good
[__] person you try to do right
five people
tell me how I take this girl out I said
listen I make a meal just a meal you
know I said let me cook for you it's
first date we have a good conversation
what happened now but all right I made
her a nice meal it wasn't me some fish
fish got some horseradish had some good
side dishes radish okay it was nice I
like cooking it's fun for me I enjoy it
yeah she hit me up right last minute I'm
like hey let's I'm cooking that why
don't you come by me we have a good
conversation she leaves we don't sleep
together we don't make out nothing it
was just a cool conversation afterwards
I texted I'm like hey it was cool but I
don't like you know this is a couple
days after I texted her I'm like hey
it's cool but I don't think like
romantic I want to revolve and what
happened this girl called me a [__] boy
a narcissist or whatever and I'm like
why I said because you made me for
dinner I was like
yeah who would do that and then just
walk away like that
a narcissist stabba
it's like yo out I would understand if I
like smashed and just threw her to the
curb or something or else that's it
it's you didn't get your way so I'm like
I'm mentally deficient
anyways all this to say I said yeah you
know what have a good day sorry it
didn't work out and I left it at that we
haven't spoken it's cool but it's just
it peeves me that we couldn't just leave
things amicably because nothing really
happened that warranted that but I think
for her she just got her hopes up off of
one date now I'm like bro you need to
chill just because I was like kind to
you and I did the bare minimum just
because in your past dudes may have
treated you like nothing I ain't my
responsibility
you know what I'm saying God damn oh I'm
just gonna be honest anyways triggered
Apple doesn't exist all right oh yeah
every now and then let me know those
little pigs I'm like really you you said
that from that you did all this stuff
oh this is it oh this is say what moving
past us okay um
yeah when I watch this video of her it's
just um
that's all it really comes down to so
yeah you know
um there's a lot of people like that out
there
just try to be mindful and try not to
date strippers
I mean Hey listen
[Laughter]
you got to be a different kind of
brother to do it's just you got to be a
different kind of brother to do your
sister today is just
sorry
A Stripper fresh is that you
if that's your grace
laughs
[Laughter]
yes damn bro hey Hey listen they gonna
play this clip if they ever catch me
they're going to take that [__] all out
of context and [__] flame your ass
with that [__]
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below video it started by the
end of it I was cooking
you were you're the one burning yeah
yeah